[Music]
hi and welcome to martial matters with
me winston marshall at the spectator
building today i'm joined by uh one of
the most prolific men i know both in
comedy but also in the commentating
commentariat world andrew doyle thank
you so much andrew for um coming here to
westminster to chat with me thanks for
having me um uh so
i don't really know how you you have the
capacity to do so much but as well as
your tv show
free speech nation you've also written
uh
free speech
and why it matters um as well as two
books you're the man behind titania
mcgraw yeah i've pronounced it correctly
yep fantastic and
she's published two books and and i i uh
went to see her show on uh uh in the
west end at the square theater i've seen
you do stand up you host the um
uh comedy show at uh the brick lane is
it bricklaying it's bethlehem
comedy unleashed yeah comedy unleashed
yeah i don't know how you have the time
for it also with that mind thank you so
much for you know absolutely my pleasure
no that's nice um so the the sort of
first thing i want to uh speak to you
about is free speech not only because
you wrote they published this book last
year on free speech um but it seems to
me that um as the kind of lens of the
cultural discourse continues to move
whether it was blm or trans or covid and
all these different things
this month particularly with both elon
musk
buying twitter and also biden launching
their quote ministry of truth it seems
like free speech is a is now really at
the center of um uh of the discourse
both at the
the top level as i've just said and and
also you know seeing sort of twitter go
wild on on these yeah two things we've
probably reached the the point haven't
we where
people are starting to realize that we
do have to defend this principle again
you know i mean that was the reason i
wrote the book is that i felt that
i'm i was aware that you have to defend
free speech in every successive
generation this isn't something that you
win the fight and it's there forevermore
and particularly at the moment it feels
like it's in kind of a pile of state and
i think um
in this country you know with the online
safety bill that the conservatives are
trying to push through that that which
will only make matters worse i have
absolutely no doubt and then as you say
the situation with twitter although this
development with elon musk is really
fascinating isn't it i mean this could
this could change the game um and
a lot of people are speculating about
you know what will be revealed by the
time musk is installed about the the
censorship practices within twitter uh
because it's so
uh sort of
layered in in mystery you know because
they're just not a transparent company
even the even the uh their terms of
service are not transparent they have
these vague nebulous ideas you get
banned and you don't know why you apply
to find out why you got banned and they
send you automated responses saying
you've been banned because you've broken
our terms of service and you say what
terms of service and they send you the
same message back and that it's all
kafkaesque it's like the trial in the
trial he is he has done something wrong
but no one will tell him what he's done
wrong no one will tell him what crime
he's committed
and uh it's it's very much like that so
i think all the matters seem to be
coming to a head at the moment which is
good because i'm glad that people are
taking more of an interest in it and
they've started to realize
that big tech censorship is a serious
threat to liberty uh and and you'll
notice
that old mantra you know twitter is a
private company they can do whatever
they want
in relation to censorship
those same people aren't saying that
anymore because now they see elon musk
in charge they think well
what they really meant when they said
twitter as a private company can do what
it wants is oh well twitter is censoring
the people i don't like so that's fine
and that that might now change who knows
i i was personally gutted to find out i
wasn't shadow banned because it implies
i'm not saying anything interesting or
provocative enough no oh you might be
and you might not know i don't
you don't show up in those things where
they hide the replies that's one of the
things
no i see but you so you sound excited
then about about master taping i'm not
that excited and surprised it probably
won't do that much but i i'm i've
enjoyed the absolute meltdown from
people on the identitarian left and the
way in which they have completely
overreacted to this news um
and that's been very funny i mean
they're talking people are actually
saying things like this is the rise of
the new third reich and uh with you know
musk in charge and uh white supremacists
or rain twitter oh absolutely insane
stuff and you do hope that one day these
people will look back at the things
they've written and think i must have
gone mad i must have said something but
that capacity for hysteria is something
that i've been surprised over the last
ever since brexit really
it's the sheer mania that people are
capable of whipping themselves up into
on social media and i'm talking about
prominent commentators and and
you know
politicians and celebrities and all
these people
figures of authority and they just get
sucked in to this hysteria this this
nonsense world the jk rowling thing is a
perfect example jk rowling who has never
said anything transphobic never written
anything transphobic uh has only ever uh
defended trans rights and um but is also
now concerned about women's rights as
well
and that has somehow translated in many
mainstream media outlets to she's a
transphobe or she says transphobic
things it's like
this this is this is uh we are we are
entering into periods of hysteria when
that kind of thing happens when they lie
when a fiction is embraced by all sorts
of people
and and you know whenever you ask them
for evidence of their claims
they can't produce them but they don't
revise their views on that basis they
stick with those views it's called
belief perseverance you know you stick
with the view even once it's been
disproved um and that's so common now
and i don't understand it because if
as has happened to me if someone points
out that i'm factually wrong about
something i'm grateful because it means
i'm not gonna make a fool of myself
anymore and i can correct the record and
and move on but that doesn't seem to be
well for a lot of people that's really
tricky because if you if
their identity is let's say being a
trans activist
and and
these things pierce the the underlying
understanding of their their life yeah
then for them to change would mean come
changing everything about life it's hard
perhaps yeah i know i mean uh peter
pagosian and james lindsey wrote a book
called how to have impossible
conversations which is about that
and they talk they call them identity
quakes um and i cite that in my book on
free speech because i think that's
exactly right the identity quake the
idea of
your whole world view suddenly shifting
underneath you and it's very
uncomfortable it's what charles darwin
experienced uh when he when he was
undertaking his work because of course
it threatened his
deeply held christian views
um and that's quite that to me is
interesting philip goss would be another
naturalist of the time
who couldn't cope with the the findings
uh of natural selection he created this
whole theory
he wrote a book called omphalos which is
which means navel
and the theory he came up with was well
adam and eve in the garden of eden adam
would have had a navel a navel only
exists if you have a biological mother
and adam didn't have a biological mother
and therefore what that is is that god
is essentially um
introducing into his creation hints of a
past that didn't exist for instance in
the garden of eden the trees would have
had rings which would have suggest age
but they were brand new
and so he came up with this really quite
poetic and beautiful theory that god had
deliberately not tricked people but had
you know introduced these elements that
made it look like the world was older
than it was he was in other words trying
to reconcile the truth of natural
selection
with his biblical faith
and he tried to find a way he was widely
ridiculed for it at the time
but i sort of underst i feel for him
because i understand what it must have
done to him have you had any moments
like that in your life yeah of course i
think um i was very attached to
uh when i was a teenager
and i just come out i was very attached
to that sort of uh gay identity that
world um
you know
it mattered to me but then of course
that was at a time when being gay was
not uh
most people weren't out you know so it's
certainly among my friendship groups
most people weren't out
um
and
in retrospect i think that was
i was
subordinating my own individuality to a
group identity
in a way that i don't think was very
helpful or healthy um
so yeah absolutely and that changed
yeah
like now i mean i've reached the point
where i mistrust whenever i like when i
was
1920 if i saw the rainbow flag outside a
building i would be like okay that's
that's comforting i can go in there and
you know i can hold someone's hand and
i'm not going to be
attacked or anything and there was a
sense of that's great and i i like that
comforting feeling if i see that flag
now i see it as a warning
of
an intolerance and the liberalism of
tribalism uh something quite unpleasant
and that's a complete about face you
know and that flag is everywhere i
noticed actually just um the other day
driving past pentonville prison where i
used to work in pennsylvania prison
briefly and and there's a rainbow flag
flying above it right actually inside
princeville prison
there were um post stonewall posters um
uh all about um the trans issue and and
it was quite surprising uh like how much
that's grown and how much that's changed
over i guess yeah not very long the the
rainbow flag as a symbol of gay pride
is important
in a context where
to be gay is dangerous
so if you were flying that flag in saudi
arabia that would make sense to me that
would be great
um
the corporations who fly the flag now
they weren't doing this before the
equalization of the age of consent they
weren't doing this before equal marriage
they weren't doing it before at a time
of section 28.
they weren't doing it when there was any
risk to do so
they're doing it now because it signals
virtue and it's easy to do now because
everyone's on board with gay rights now
so
um it is meaningless to me uh and and
because stonewall it is my belief that
stonewall are the biggest threat to gay
rights at the moment and which is so sad
because when they started out they were
really important they were instrumental
in
not just legislative change but cultural
shifts attitudes um they did such
important work and now that they have
decided that being gay doesn't mean
being same-sex attracted which is at the
heart of being gay
they say it's the same gender attracted
they've revised the definition on their
website and their promotional materials
they are promoting a new religion of
gender identity ideologies um they are
saying that we all have an innate sexed
soul um and the consequence of that is
that it it it works against
all of the achievements of gay rights
which was predicated on the recognition
of biological reality because gay men
are attracted to other men and gay women
are attracted to other women and that
was what we were shamed for for so many
years and that's what we were
attacked for and now we have activists
basically saying if you're a lesbian and
you're not you and you are excluding
people with penises from your dating
pool you are a bigot the head of
stonewall nancy kelly calls them sexual
racists right so we are having that's
the old homophobic trope you know you
just haven't found the right man yet
saying that to a lesbian or you know or
maybe there's something wrong with you
maybe you've got trauma maybe you've got
psychological problems and that's why
you you aren't open these are just old
this is old-school homophobia from the
80s and before being recycled in the
name of progressivism and i see that
flag now as tied to that so whereas for
that flag for me once represented
gay pride gay rights equality
unity it now represents division uh and
homophobia
wow um back to free speech sorry so i've
digressed no no but
very interesting and it's not a
topic i know too much about the
stonewall and china under to be honest
when when you start talking about what
stone will now
try and argue for or the modern
progressive
theories behind sexuality and gender i
get a bit confused because it's there's
so much gymnastics going on so much back
and forth that yeah it's i can sort of
understand
the you know the the as you described
your understanding of of uh the original
stonewall
gay rights but this modern one is it's
kind of hard to keep up with oh it's
unrecognizable it doesn't support gay
people it's not there for gay people uh
it's it's there for people who believe
in gender identity which is fine people
have every right to believe in gender
identity and to identify however they
wish i don't have any problem with that
um but that's not
uh that's not looking out for the
interests of gay and lesbian people and
a lot of trans people for whom
biological sex is important because
otherwise there'll be no such thing as
trans so you know this
they are on a crusade
um to
promote a pseudo reality and they are
doing very well at it although now
there's a push back you know lots of
companies and corporations are pushing
them out governmental departments and
things and
i just wish the nhs could
rid themselves of the influence of
stonewall you know i saw a thing the
other day
about blood the blood donation unit at
the nhs talking about how they
they treat their patients on the basis
of how they identify what sex they
identify with not their biological sex
well that matters in a medical context
gender identity is irrelevant when it
comes to medicine uh so where is that
pushback coming from because
from my experience with institutions
like i walked past islington town hall
the other day and there was a rainbow
flag as well i don't see the pushback i
see it being fully embraced by the
internet and maybe you're right maybe
i'm just seeing the pushback because i
associate with people who are pushing
back and maybe we are in the minority
yeah sure but but you know you have had
things like um the government advise
their various departments to
to rid themselves of stonewall you've
got um
um also ofcom channel 4 various bodies
divorcing themselves from the stonewall
diversity champions scheme um there is
more more there's the stephen nolan
series on bbc sounds which was very very
critical of stonewall and its influence
in the bbc um it's so embedded in the
bbc though i don't know how they would
now
extricate themselves from it but there
is a push back
and i think ultimately it will be
successful um but it's going to take
some time i think yeah um so uh in this
book uh i think for people who who are
new to the kind of the history of free
speech philosophy this is a great
starting point and you re refer back to
uh mill and milton and um
you you say in the book
the best argument in favor of
restricting speech is that of incitement
and so um i guess my question is to you
uh to you is what are your lines on free
speech where would you say that's too
far when what is not acceptable to you
in terms of free speech um
okay i would say
well i am i think a free speech
absolutist in so far as on
it when it comes to uh i mean i draw a
distinction in the book and i'm talking
about the way in which speech can be
used as a mechanism to commit a crime
but the problem there is not speech in
of itself so for instance
perjury
espionage blackmail libel
you know these are all ways in which you
have
committed a crime
uh and the crime has been committed via
speech but but for me to say i don't
think you should have the right to
blackmail someone
that doesn't mean i that's an anti-free
speech stance it's completely compatible
with a free speech sound so we have to
be clear about what we mean by by free
speech i think anyone should be able to
say whatever they want so long as it
does not infringe on the rights of
others very directly and and thereby
break the law
if you're talking about incitement i
would like to see a debate about that
because
the potential for words to lead to
violence is very very small and
you would have to prove to me that there
is that
causality
and even where it were to be proven we
would still have to have a discussion
about whether that necessarily means we
should limit
speech now in america they have the
brandenburg test where they will say you
know incitement to violence can only be
proven if there was a sense that it was
an imminent danger so for instance an
example would be a demagogue standing in
a crowd and i mentioned this example in
the book
and he's surrounded by his followers and
he points to someone and says kill him
now and he's whipped them up into her
friends and he says kill that person
that would be a very clear case of an
imminent that would that would meet the
brandenburg test of incitement to
violence
um but the trouble is that that concept
of incitement is used to
as a pretext to silence forms of speech
they will say for instance that boris
johnson using phrases like the surrender
bill or talking about betrayal when it
comes to the parliament parliament's
reaction to brexit
that that is inciting violence
right what they're talking about is
robust political language and it's very
dangerous to start
eliding that with you know the tall
trees broadcast during the rwandan
genocide you know and this is what
people are doing they will invoke joe
cox and say that this came about because
because of words they will say you know
this happened with the killing of david
amis all of a sudden we have this
conversation in parliament about
uh trolls online and about how we in
other words it became a pretext to
censor speech but there wasn't there was
no suggestion that this had anything to
do
with with trolls online in fact it
definitely didn't
so you know
this
so i i would say when it comes to
limits on free speech no i think on
balance
i
think it is safe like so when in a free
society there is going to be some
horrible people who say really really
horrible things
and the question shouldn't be do we
approve of what that person has to say
do i approve
of the man standing at speaker's corner
screaming that homosexuals should be
killed no i don't approve of that i
actually take it quite personally um
but the question isn't about whether i
endorse the speech that is being uttered
the question is what would i rather have
would i rather have a society where that
guy gets to say what he wants
or would i rather have a society in
which we empower the state
to decide on the acceptable parameters
of speech because what you're doing is
you're setting a dangerous precedent
that to me i know enough about history
to know that that never leads to good
things
so i think that's the question we you
people need to ask themselves when it
comes to free speech well then you'll be
very worried
when you see i don't know if you saw
obama last week when he announced this
uh what's it called again it's called
the disinformation governance board or
yeah he's talking about
fighting disinformation on social media
he he talks about how uh the um these
big tech companies are
taking on responsibility to monitor
speech hate speech and incitement to
violence but then he goes on to say but
that's not enough
yeah and that is quite worrying because
if
he said that he said that's not enough
yeah
and if if that if if the me if you can
justify anything if you if it's deemed
to be uh um
morally uh you know yeah desirable end
um so if obama says who's gonna who's
gonna control what and and that is i i
see that as a pushback against musk's uh
takeover yes i mean that's scary um
it feels like a stage has been skipped
doesn't it it's like they've
it is taken now as axiomatic that speech
leads to violence or that speech can be
a form of violence and that's why that
that'll be what that is based on the the
desire to censor disinformation is based
on a mistrust of the public and a
mistrust of the marketplace of ideas and
the way in which bad ideas are
traditionally resolved which is through
better ideas uh and through argument and
exposure through criticism and ridicule
or whatever you like uh even protest and
um
that i think is the the
the problem here is they are taking as
read something which isn't true
um
and
and there's all sorts of ways in which
that can be exploited if a government is
saying they're going to clamp down on
disinformation well they're the ones who
are going to get to decide what
constitutes disinformation and that
could be something that is critical of
the government
you know i think it's a horrendous idea
particularly in america given their
first amendment
you would expect this not to
not to have happened
yeah so if you were let's say masked now
and he i think describes as a free
speech absolutist as you do yeah how do
you regulate twitter what would you do
there if you were walking into the
office there what would you do to one of
those things firstly i would um
i would yeah i would make it a free
speech platform the reason why you have
a block function on twitter
is that it protects the free speech on
the platform weirdly it's it's it's
it means that when i see something that
i find horrific on twitter i can block
that person i never have to see it again
and that's what i do
um
and that means that twitter and the
authorities at twitter don't have to get
involved in my experience of the
platform they don't have to intervene
and decide on my behalf what is good for
me to see and what is bad for me to see
because i've done it myself that's what
it's for uh you can curate your own
experience on social media the function
is there and i think it should be used
um
and then you get the really stupid
argument that blocking someone on
twitter is
encroaching on their free speech which
only really genuinely stupid people say
so we don't have to worry about that um
but you know i mean i do address it but
you know it's so obvious why that's not
true um but the
yeah so i would say what he should do is
is
well you know disband the trust and
safety council firstly because they have
a really scary name why would you call
them a trust in safety
i mean they sound like you know
an orwellian nightmare it's ridiculous
so get rid of that because you've got
this group of academics from around the
world who are telling twitter advising
twitter on what speech they should allow
and obviously that's going to tie in
with their own ideological inclinations
this is why twitter routinely ban
gender-critical feminists because of
their opinion some people have been
banned for even quoting debates on the
gender recognition act that go on in
parliament so you can be thrown off the
platform for uh
quoting what's said in a parliamentary
debate that's not good for democracy so
you know get rid of that
have some terms of service that are
really really clear and obviously it is
a private company if elon musk's running
it's a private company if he wants to
say i'm going to run a platform where
we don't have homophobic racist sexist
speech that's up to him but he has to be
very clear in those terms of service
what he means by that because the
problem is that those words don't really
mean much anymore you know you can be
accused of homophobia or racism when
you've never said or done anything
homophobic or racist
so again i don't trust those people i
don't trust those
people in silicon valley to make those
decisions the safest way to approach it
is to say anyone can say what they want
and the user gets to decide what they
see and what they don't and that's
that's what i would do
great um well uh hopefully if he
struggles um he'll uh he'll come to you
for requesting
um i wanted to ask you about uh titania
mcgrath uh did i pronounce her right
because this is how i came across uh you
originally okay and actually i got
pretty triggered when i first read her
because i'm sorry yeah i was i i saw the
tweets and i got pretty enraged
about these sort of moronic ultra
progressive uh uh tweets and uh it took
me a minute to work out it was a it was
a joke yes but it's been kind of a
miracle it's huge and um
what's that journey been how did it
start uh it started because i was uh
frustrated uh that there didn't appear
to be many comedians uh going after this
new
very intolerant very upper middle class
movement of people who wanted to speak
on behalf of minorities in this really
patronizing
way and it's just fundamentally a
liberal world view and you know i'm a
liberal and i i wanted to mock it you
know and so
i did it really for myself i didn't
expect it to go anywhere i i created an
account
i wanted her to be a slam poet i would
have this idea that she wrote really
terrible self-righteous poetry which i
always enjoyed writing so i did that and
then um it just escalated and i don't
know why really i um i think it's just
uh you know there was an appetite for it
i guess uh and then she got banned and
the ban was what really kicked it when
was that
do you know what it was pretty early on
it was about six months after i'd
created the character and what was she
banned for
it was a tweet about
a ukip
rally i can't remember the it was about
punching them
basically she put a photograph of a ukip
rally said i'm going off to this you get
ready to punch people in the name of
tolerance or something like that i can't
remember the exact phrase but it was a
complete ban and i think it was because
they thought it was inciting but
whatever i don't know what it was but
that got but then when because at that
point she had enough high profile
followers
who were made a bit of a fuss about it
so they reinstated her
a day later on the grounds of satire on
the grounds of saturday presumably they
didn't tell me why they don't tell you
why but they um
and but so she'd been banned for
basically 24 hours even though they
emailed me saying it was permanent
they reversed the decision
and then she wrote an article for
quillette
about her 24-hour ban
it was called now i know how nelson
mandela felt
and
you know and so it was like she used
that as currency and then it became more
and i think i got like 30 000 followers
that day after she came back because
it's that the streisan effect isn't it
it's when you try and ban something and
it's just sort of gone on since then
really and do you still have now
pushback with it do you have people
complaining about it or uh are you
winding up people like liberals like me
or are you is it does it piss off the
progressives well this is a big idea
that it's ridiculous this is what i
don't understand over the past few days
lately because you know i've written the
two books i've done the live show i've
got other things on my plate so i don't
tweet as often as i used to but then for
the last week i have been i've just been
tweeting every day just i don't know why
just because i felt like it and what's
so shocking is so many people still fall
for it
so
there's a lot of people who don't know
who she is and they they get very angry
and they've been lots of angry responses
about a couple of tweets she's done over
the last week i mean really really
furious uh and that's that's been quite
funny
you know
this is that's the mischievous element
in me but you know it's got but the fact
that people do think it's real
even now
suggests that there is a problem with
that movement you know because you can
say the most absurd
possible thing
and it will come true and what's next
for her don't know really i mean i've uh
we did have the live show which i'd love
to tour
might tour it we had a tour booked in
for then the pandemic hit
um and then um
i might like to develop her
in some other way television perhaps or
something like that i've i've put
together a few ideas along that line
but you know it's very difficult i think
for
something that satirizes this movement
to get anywhere insofar as the a lot of
the gatekeepers of the industry wouldn't
be happy about that so i don't think it
necessarily will you have to kind of do
it yourself
which is what i've been doing yeah um
you've been doing that at comedy
unleashed uh
your comedy um club in east london at
which you've called the home of free
thinking comedy yeah which implies that
free thinking comedy doesn't exist
elsewhere or it or i mean it doesn't
need to be stated it does exist it's an
all comedy free thinking no i mean it it
does exist it's just not the norm in the
comedy the the comedy weirdly the comedy
industry is one of the most subject to
group think that i'm familiar with i
mean i know groupthink tends to infect
every walk of life to a degree but the
sheer level of conformity among
comedians is quite a surprise has been a
surprise to me uh the way in which there
is a very narrow overton window of
acceptable opinions on the comedy
circuit
and the fact that comedians t seem to be
you know they're meant to be the
disruptors in society they're meant to
be the ones who think outside the box
but they all think the same and they all
have the same accepted creed and
accepted scripts i'm not all of them
obviously um is that true if you look
to the biggest comedians let's say uh in
the states at the moment yeah rogan
chappelle
south park still
huge and family that you couldn't
possibly call them woke or progressive
they're or maybe progressive but but
they're they're they're huge and they're
very much disrupting
uh the the yeah yeah group think or uh
or are you referring to sort of lower
level comedians in the uk no i think i'm
referring to the uk
uh i was surprised when i was in l.a and
i went to the comedy store there and the
i saw
many many comedians i'd never heard of
doing stuff that you just wouldn't see
on the circuit in the uk it seemed quite
normal there um and it it there is a
just a different sense about it here i
mean i've experienced this first hand
over here because i used to run a
stand-up course for young comics between
the ages of 20 and 26 and i did that for
about seven years and it was on saturday
afternoons and i did three terms a year
so it was like 10 week terms
and you know
i met many years ago when i started
doing that it was for a theater in
central london
you know the the the comics i was
working with they were really
interesting they were
doing all sorts of stuff subversive
stuff and and really talented and
and then each as each term went by and
each year went by
there was a more sense in which they
were starting to police each other these
young comics are saying yeah that's
really problematic what you're saying
you shouldn't do that you can't talk
about that because you're white or
you're straight or whatever and and this
it got worse and so every time we ended
up having these debates about this stuff
and i was like this shouldn't be coming
from comedians
there was even one comic who said that
she would go to
clubs and
go up to the comedians afterwards and
tell them which jokes they shouldn't
have told
right and this was that so in other
words you get this situation where young
comics are policing each other
you know egged on by people like the
guardian and people like that who think
that the job of the comedian is to
reiterate
voguish trends
um and so it was weird seeing that and
then and then they wouldn't rehire me
because one of the um
members said they were felt unsafe
because of a titania tweet this was in
the early days of titania
uh and they said because of that i
couldn't come back anywhere but but by
that point i i probably
was quite glad to be free of it i was
sort of doing out loyalty at that point
but
but i do think so was comedy unleashed
on started out of necessity because you
weren't you could no longer perform at
those other places or no i mean i i
look
there are a number of clubs have you
felt other places where you felt
pushback because of your yeah there are
places that won't book me anymore uh
and that's fine because i'm not
i'm not so much interested in doing the
club circuit anymore you know i mean i i
did a tour my a solo show tour
just before the pandemic that was the
last time i've done any sort of major
stand up i did the edinburgh fringe
that year as well
but really um
i like doing the occasional gig at
comedy unleashed or like i did the
opening spot for titanium yeah yeah you
know i'll do that but i'm not
you know
i'm not really that bothered about
getting going back to clubs too much but
um yeah and a number of the
comedians who i know who i do consider
really free thinking and subversive they
don't get booked
in in some of these clubs i mean mary
burke
is a comic who had her gig cancelled in
brighton because
someone complained to the venue said
i've seen some of her material online it
makes me feel unsafe and then they just
they just scuppered the gig um you know
that is becoming more normal so what
does that mean for british comedy then
well no i think things are slightly
changing i think i think um people are
getting bored with the style of comedy
where someone just basically reads out a
guardian opinion piece
uh i think that's becoming it's just
very establishment very boring and and i
think um
ultimately that's why comedy unleashed
work so well because
the audience are comedy literate they're
an audience that come back again and
again they don't expect
not to hear things that you know they
they they expect that someone might say
something that pushes their buttons a
little bit
you're not gonna get a member of that
audience come up and say i was offended
and therefore you shouldn't book that
comic again because we just tell them
where to go and they know that but also
they just know not to expect that they
know that comedy isn't a safe space
in that way um you know and again like
i'm not saying there aren't other
brilliant clubs
you know we're we're a club like any
other it's just that the only real
difference is
that you know people do the same club
sets they do at our night as they do on
other nights it's just that sometimes a
comedian will say to me i really want to
try something that i can't do at other
clubs and we'll say okay do it that's
the only really real difference that
occasionally we get someone trying
something out that for whatever reason
they feel they can't do elsewhere um
and you know maybe that perception
perception's false maybe you can do in
any way but the perception exists and
and it's certainly the case that a lot
of comedians self-censor with a view to
getting on in the industry and we just
encourage people to say whatever you
want and you know you can do what you
want and it's going to be fine and if it
doesn't work so what yeah yeah you know
what's your um
uh i actually didn't know until meeting
you that you were involved with jonathan
pie in the early days yeah and and
that's a very political um uh
project and and i would say that i
wouldn't say you're well i guess your
stand ups for mildly political and
certainly cultural can be and uh
what's your um are you fond of that that
your work there jonathan pie and and
what what was that experience for you
well i wrote uh the character
co-wrote the character with tom who
created the character for three years
for the first three years
of the of the roughly around that um
and i just find that
i get you know i i have to move on to
other things
um i think
i'm
proud of some of the videos we did
uh some less so it's like anything else
really i think i think um it was very
political though it was very
uh because my standard at that point
wasn't all that political but then of
course brexit happened so you know and
actually it was really helpful because i
was writing a lot
about
politics and that did end up informing
my stand-up actually at the time um so
that was quite interesting um
and i always like writing scripts for
other people i like writing
four characters well you write in comedy
first or politics first comedy yeah okay
and so when did when did you sort of get
excited or or when did your interest in
politics develop well i start well i
mean i've always been interested in
politics um but i started writing for
spiked magazine um on a regular basis
and
that was it was thomas slater who's now
the editor of spite who was then deputy
editor who persuaded me to do that
and uh that was great i think just
writing about
politics
consolidated my ideas about politics and
actually got me to change my mind about
something it's in the act of having to
articulate your views that you end up
seeing the flaws in them um and so that
was really good for me to do that and i
think
uh
now it's sort of second nature to me but
only because i
i did that i think yeah um so i
understand that you are about to publish
another book
well can you tell us about that uh it's
a book it's called the new puritans um
it's how the religion of social justice
captured the western world that's the
subtitle it is um going to be out in
september it is finished um
and it's sort of ready to go the problem
with it was i mean i've been revising it
over the last four or five months
and the problem is that every day
there's stuff i could add like every day
there's a new news story there's a new
development all the rest of it and and
so it's quite a relief at this point now
it's it's cut off now i'm not going to
add any more all sorts of things might
change between now and september you
know how quickly this stuff moves but
the broad the broad
idea of the book is to
talk about this new religion and i do
perceive it to be a religion and to draw
uh
to try and i wanted to create an
accessible way for people to understand
how it works because i don't think
people do i think people are put off by
the language so much of this culture war
if you like is a battle of language it's
about
ideologues who change definitions of
words whilst denying that they are
changing the definitions of words
there's a lot of institutional
gaslighting going on you know and
and they want it to seem
impenetrable
impenetrable because of the language
they use and and
the you know the the the esoteric
terminology toxic masculinity
heteronormativity you know all of this
sort of stuff and so i wanted to find a
way to make it accessible make it under
uh comprehensible and also to talk about
how we can push back against it and
that's what the book is about really um
and i've drawn a lot of comparisons i
mean the book opens talking about what
happened in salem massachusetts
during the witch trials because i see so
many parallels between
you know because this i call them the
new puritans but really they're not
anything like the puritans of old and so
far as for one thing the puritans of the
the puritan colonists of america had a
complete understanding of their own
unworthiness before god they were
constantly doubting themselves they
didn't know if they were the elect or
the damned
the the puritans of today the new
puritans they call them uh they are they
they never doubt their own certainty
they think they're right and they cannot
be shaken from that they you know so
they're very different beasts but what i
do think is comparable is the way in
which a climate of mistrust and fear can
generate and uh the promotion of lies
the promotion of a fantasy reality
and leads to terrible consequences in
salem it's the girls claiming that they
were seeing spirits and devils and they
were possessed they were seeing witches
and people got killed 20 people lost
their lives
because of that um and it was only when
um enough people spoke out and said
there are no witches
you're this isn't
this isn't true that it stopped and i
see a parallel with today is that
you know
everyone knows that there are two sexes
everyone knows uh that
um
the idea well all sorts of ideological
positions that are promoted such as
critical race theory gender identity
ideology um this pushback against free
speech everyone everyone missed most
people mistrust that kind of thing
we know the difference between truth and
illusion but we we're being asked to buy
into the illusion on a on a grand scale
and i think
when sufficient numbers speak out it
will stop you know we look at what
happens with jk rowling everyone's
terrified because they see how much they
pile into her an attacker and call her a
witch
and and so people don't speak out and
that's all it is isn't it
so there's a sort of uh
element of hope in what you're saying
because you're saying if you've got a
critical mass of people to speak out
then enough of this nonsense but that
presupposes that actually most people
agree with what you're saying well they
do don't they i mean i'm not convinced
of that but the world's i've come from
say the music industry yeah it would
it's majority progressive and i used to
live in new york vast majority
progressive i'm not conv and then if you
look at also how popular these
politicians are on the on the left yeah
with you know they have millions of of
of likes and on on their tweets and and
stuff like this if that's a measure of
their popularity but also they are let's
say in the states yeah they're they're
getting power or you know political
power so it's
it's not i'm not convinced that the um
that there is a critical mass to get
because it it seems to me to be more
split almost 50 50. you could be right i
mean the the data would seem suggest not
in so far as you know more in common did
a survey they estimate that uh thirteen
percent of the uk would fit into that
critical social justice progressive
brexit right wow which means as well
that they are a minority in every
generation so this sort of myth that
what this is is that the older
generation are struggling to come to
terms with change isn't borne out by the
stats because actually the majority of
young people would be on my side in this
fight but but it but it's about what
what are the it goes back to the overton
window what are what are the acceptable
words to say what are the acceptable
opinions to hold
um
i i have no doubt that a lot of the
people you're describing who are the
cheerleaders for this ideological
movement
they are doing so partly because they
know that that is the way that they can
progress in their career they're not
going to have their reputations
threatened they're not going to lose
their jobs or the rest of it it's a
self-preservation thing partly it's uh
partly but i'm
i think i haven't come across so many
people that do it
in let's say the music industry where my
background is i think that people really
believe no i think they believe it too
yeah i i don't think it's insincere when
they're no no i don't i was going on to
say i think i think partly it's
self-preservation i mean because the
kind of people i get messages on all the
time from people within the common
industry saying things like i'm glad
you're saying the things i can't say
yeah i'll get that
right so those would be the sorts i'm
describing here the ones who are four
reasons of self-preservation parroting
the accepted creed right so there's a
contingent there i think i'm with you
though i think most of the people who
parrot this stuff do sincerely believe
it you know because it's they've been
ideologically captured and they i think
it is sincere and i think it's well
intentioned largely as well but i don't
think they represent the majority i
don't think there's evidence of that
i think they seem more prevalent than
they are
because of the amplification effect of
social media and that and certainly you
and i come from the creative arts
where they do predominate so we have a
skewed view of this we we think
this is now
everywhere
the majority of people you can talk to
on the street won't have a clue what
these people are talking about and they
would think it's nonsense
so
that's that's it's the elites again it's
it it it's when elites have have
been captured and that's why i go back
to salem because none of that would have
happened if it weren't for the
magistrates the people in power or the
clergymen
saying we believe in these girls and
their visions
you know and that's that's why i think
it's important although it's it's
interesting to me that
there's one case when when the hysteria
spread to the neighboring towns and it
went to andover
and the girls did their usual thing and
they they cried out witchery on a local
dignitary and he said okay
uh i'm gonna sue you for defamation
and then they stopped
straight away
so there were exactly so even at the
time there were examples of
people in authority knowing it wasn't
true
whenever the girls accused
say the priest's wife hale's wife
reverend hale's wife was accused the
magistrates would say no you've made a
mistake
right which means they don't really
believe it and that's quite interesting
to me so you've got the the elites of
our time and that's why i think these
are
the best way to see the high priest of
critical social justice is they are the
clergy of our time
the elite clergy yeah uh
and it's that combination of what you've
described sincere ideological capture
or self-preservation parroting the words
that you're meant to say i think it's a
combination of both yeah um
and i think therefore i am hopeful yeah
maybe i mean maybe you're more
pessimistic
than i am but i
i vacillate on that sometimes i'm
but you know it's the same with writing
the free speech book i i'd say at the
end of the book
maybe
if i'm lucky enough to reach old age at
that point
there will just be a very tight limit on
the words you can say and
maybe books will have had lots of their
old books stripped out and burnt maybe
that will be the case but at least i can
say well i tried
and that's all i can say well actually i
get my hope from people like you who
have the courage to speak out and defend
these liberal values like you do and and
i've said this uh before the interview
started you do it in a very gracious way
i don't see you doing any ad hominem i
don't see you attacking people you do it
in a very nice way an honest way and and
uh and if only more people
who believe in free speech and liberal
values have this the same approach as
you i think would actually i don't think
the ad hominem thing is helpful i don't
think saying
you know just throwing mud instead of
engaging in arguments is helpful i think
the one exception is if someone's
online and they're just sending abuse my
way i might i treat it like a heckle and
then i go into comedy mode and i might
do and you could argue that that's not
hormone but i will never i will never
i will never
try and falsely ascribe a motivation to
a political opponent just on the basis
that i suspect they think that i will
always take people at face value and
and assume what they are being truthful
in what they argue um and i will
um
never just throw insults at someone
because i disagree with them i don't see
the point i think it's self-defeating it
is you've lost the art as soon as you
someone uses ad hominem against me i i
kind of disengage because they've
already lost the argument exactly
because if they can't play the ball they
play the man instead and it's like okay
well then
you're a blocker
you know within this
um so but you don't doesn't mean you
have to block them you can just ignore
them
no because if you don't block them they
will mass report you and and you open
yourself up to that vulnerability oh
yeah i've been there uh yeah so just you
know there's no point like so
you we all make decisions about who we
can
productively engage with
you know i can
productively engage with someone who has
i don't know reservations about
immigration or who believes that um
uh
we don't need women's only spaces or
what you know
if they're coming from it from us if
they're willing to have a discussion in
an adult way
i can have that discussion no matter how
sensitive or difficult the topic might
be
but if someone's screaming and tearing
their hair out and calling you an evil
bigot fascist
i'm not going to talk to that what's the
point yeah it's like you're not going to
get anywhere you're not going to
persuade them
um you're just going to frustrate
yourself they're like vampires on social
media sucking the life out of you so
just just block them
just block them yeah andrew doyle thank
you so much for your time and it's been
wonderful chatting to you and i'm sure
listeners will have found that
fascinating thank you thanks very much
[Music]
[Music]
you